[Music]
bill burr the comedian bill burr made
the biggest splash at the grammys
bill burr contradicted political
correctness take a listen to his uh
introduction to one of the awards how
are you
was i the only one who wanted to kill
himself during that piano solo
um i bought a suit for this i thought it
was going to be on tv i'm such a [ __ ]
i am losing so much money right now all
right
shout out to all the rock stars that i
wanted to meet tonight who are watching
at home instead i'm talking to you don
dawkin
all right what i'm old that was my first
concert
all right here are the next categories
all right hey how many uh
feminists are like going nuts why is
this this white male doing all this
latino stuff
it was by far the highlight of of the
night
i didn't watch the whole thing i'm just
assuming it was the only clip i've seen
that
that made me chuckle so bill berwick
said there he says wait a second
this isn't even the grammys you're not
no one's here you're all just zooming in
you idiots what do you do
okay well this is a waste and okay now i
gotta read all these spanish guy names
i bet they're going to get really angry
at me right and so people people are
trying to
cancel bill burr and call him a racist
and a you know white supremacist and all
that kind of stuff
now if you're not a fan of bill burr
you you might be persuaded by these
kinds of attacks
uh however if you do follow bill bird
all you will know
that he's married to a black woman he's
obviously not a racist
if a guy married to a black woman can be
a racist then
racism doesn't mean anything anymore
this reminds me of one time
david webb a conservative commentator
was
he was hosting radio and a woman called
in a black
liberal woman called in and they were
disagreeing and she said well you you
only think that david because of your
white privilege
and and david said are you sure about
that yeah i know it's your white
privilege he goes you know i
i think if we were in studio or on tv
right now you might
change your opinion because david webb
is a black man
you you hear this phrase racism white
supremacy it's just thrown out it just
means bad it's just like throwing
spaghetti at the wall and then
occasionally people get embarrassed by
this sort of thing i think bill birdo
has exactly the right approach
just laugh at this kind of nonsense
laugh at the pc stuff they get so
angry when you laugh at it so first you
have to laugh then you have to be bold
though you have to go out and follow
that up
with action if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]
you